bon ça devrait ça devrait bien se passer
bien se passer vous inquiétez pas moi je
vais comme d'hab lancé le petit le petit
hosting et je vais mourir le chat donc
c'est toujours les premières secondes
pour ça qu'on débute en avance aussi
pour avoir bien le temps comme il faut
de tout faire le chat est ouvert à la
visite stream vous héberge c'est
exactement ce qu'on voulait voir et donc
on doit être là je vérifier que youtube
sont ouverts j'ai vérifié qt ou marche
ce qui serait quand même la bonne
nouvelle ce qui serait l'embellie comme
il y est mathieu et le chatoiement je
vois personne dedans et ça y est micro
ni 91 jojo ça y est ça commence à
arriver et youtube aussi il est il est
live donc c'est parfait ya pierre mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui suivent via via tweets
et de moins en moins via youtube
c'est vrai qu'on a le chat qui est de ce
côté là salut à ethan salut à bully
sandales star zelder mauvais followed by
hier on a perdu dans notre petit match
contre la serbie là c'est dommage on
n'était pas loin
je n'étais pas loin si on était très
très loin en fait
bon je vais arrêter quand même norbourg
nombreux à participer je sais pas quand
on jouera contre le pérou d'ailleurs on
doit jouer contre le pérou un match qui
est plus ou moins décisif j'ai rien
compris
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'il faut pas
que perron j'espère que ce sera ce sera
le pérou justement pour quoi que je dise
ça sera pas le pérou bonjour regard des
deux côtés du coup on va se faire le
petit wang hao avec les noirs ouais
j'espère qu'on va se le faire après une
nulle et jamais un mauvais résultat et
anne avec les noirs pour moi la partie
vraiment importante ouais c'est le nez
peau ding séné pudding la partie pour
moi vraiment importante importante alors
mathieu qui est en train de revenir à
mon avis en train d'entendre commence à
bouger vraiment s'en va
c'est le gang des chemises accord que ça
va être quand au nom d'allah mais on a
une jolie serait ce que tu vas faire
marquer à quand on s'appelait alors je
sais pas la semaine bleue ou noire
un bleu et noir m c'est pas tout à fait
là mais elles se ressemblent en bas
c'est bien on est en chemise
ouais je m'en vais me mettre une chemise
jean dauger mieux dormi chant forment
une chemise voire d'être bouillant
aujourd'hui ouais j'suis pas main c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal mais ça va tu
continues les prépas les échecs ça se
passe bien tu bosses non d'ailleurs j'ai
fait rupo veut en fait j'avais un peu
trop bossé pour un parti jean caron n'a
pas intéressé hier je suis reposé ajinca
juan as tu as trop intéressé par
d'ailleurs irin est beau aussi c'était
très intéressant mais bourrières j'ai
quand même suivi toutes les parties 1
mais j'ai pas analysé enfin pas plus que
ça et merci et jugeant reprises pour
remercier je te coupe je remercie pas de
maxime qui a pris un abonnement à la
chaîne chez ascom merci à pattes maxime
lui dit qu'ils n'y soient pas trop
bouillant matchs au dessus de 38 degrés
c'est la presse voilà aussi 38° tu es
mal finir j'ai passé la journée à
l'impression de la fièvre peut faire
c'est pas aujourd'hui qui doivent
annoncer qu'on sera on sera confiné plus
longtemps que prévu
je sais pas moi je vois de frasil je
suis confiné jusqu'à la fin de l'année
je suis pour en faire on n'a pas le
choix donc mais ce que je disais nous on
a de la chance mine de rien les gens se
rendent pas compte qu'elles ont beau de
chez nous la plupart du temps du coup ça
ne choque - ouais ouais ça ne compte pas
spécialement rêve après bourse un manque
de petites promenades soit les quais de
bordeaux ça serait pas mal mais au
prochaine fois ouais ça ça devrait
revenir à leur attention qu'il ya ma
caméra alors c'est un peu la mauvaise
news j'ai ma caméra qui a planté chose
où la motion browser on va s'en va le
régler mais ma caméra a planté alors 5
j'ai un beau fruit alors attends c'est
un peu c'est un peu la très mauvaise
nouvelle
je suis pas sûr de tours alors attends
je vais tenter un truc pour voir leurs
maîtres mais sinon va être très mal
sinon tu relances st ouais mais j'aime
pas trop relancer ouais ok je pense que
je verrais que j'ai réussi à redémarrer
j'ai réussi
ça aurait pu s'arrêter à la mauvaise
news ouais ouais apparemment apparemment
ils doivent alors annoncé ils doivent
annoncer que ça va passer à quatre
semaines firent la 4e ils avanceront
kurma 6 après ils verront ouailles à des
questions une question intéressante de
manga ou parce qu'il va jouer anglaise
mais en fait il est tellement
surprenante chez moi ce que la seule
partie où il faut qu'ils jouent les
anglais il ya peut-être pas la feria et
c'est bien fait masser un web très bonne
partie des boucles mais bon show
d'ouverture j'avais déjà regardé que
cette ligne était une des plus
dangereuses pour le non mais j'avais pas
h4 quand je n'ai pas poussé l'oeil h4 le
lecavalier f5 damas trois s'inquiétait
vraiment bien joué mais bastl après pas
par contre oui mais ben prépare c'est là
que ça c'est revoir phosagro derrière tu
vois non mais je suis pas cadré on en
avait parlé je trouve que des pauvres
c'est un de ceux qui l'ont concerné par
le commente ça se voit on compare de
phase i believe débite des variantes il
a l'air à fond il est motivé je trouve
qu'il joue pas si bien mais il mérite en
fait 1 117 ha il a souffert d'une
caruana de l'ouverture mais s'est bien
battu et tu penses qu'il aurait une
chance contre magnus unemo pas du tout
avec yannick hier on était un peu en
fait moins dans ma tête je suis pas du
tout mais quand je regarde c'est un des
rares qui fait chier magnifique homme
est alors à ce qu'un pays est rapide il
peut avoir sa chance et mentalement il
est solide il a l'air totalement il est
nommé l'ema monstreux il ya trois
tournant important dans l'année il gagne
langue n 2 mais les jeux grand prix
qu'il a gagné le grand prix hyper hyper
au premier tour contre un mec fort non
hypercontent qui déjà oui il fait ok
perdre au premier tour n'a pas le temps
de te lancer qui voit pas la fin
ça peut arriver à tout le monde de
perdre au plus tôt il avait perdu contre
qui déjà il avait froid que les c'était
un premier tour pas facile nabarra c'est
la baraque il a perdu je sais pas
c'était pas un
c'était au grand prix c'est à quel grand
prix que la veille du premier tour
il a gagné moscou c'est ça hein et pau
je sais plus où il a perdu au premier
tour et je me rappelle plus loin j'ai
oublié de prendre mon ordinateur bien
ici à hambourg il avait perdu au premier
tour
voilà il a perdu mais il avait perdu
contre qui alors mais c'est contre qui
carlos c'était contre malades contre 12
d'hawaï contre duda peu et contre tous
d'arrêt ça ne dit bien quelque chose oui
il avait un il a d'ailleurs au camp pris
l'avion ce qu'on disait avec fap des des
tirages avec la ddt aussi d'ailleurs et
avec matt donc elle fait tout le monde
tout le monde tout on a parlé de ça mais
il avait eu des tirages beaucoup plus
difficile que maxime parce que tout est
au premier tour c'est quand même pas
topalov la baraque
c'était très chaud ces kits opi non non
il avait perdu contre tous dao premier
tour
guéant rapide il avait perdu dans les
rapides duda c'est quand même pas un
cadeau comme projet complètement saoul
côté mais le frein de donneurs il faut
qu'ils qui change sa manière d'approcher
le haut niveau or ils sont tous passés
par là un moment toute ma coach et
l'offre en une scène un macbook à la
culture qui veulent faire travailler un
flat ben là dessus mais bon tout le
monde n'a pas le glas d'un ayant droit
de vote
je sais pas je crois que tu en as parlé
de façon la chaîne geiger entendu mais
pas tous la grille tube c'est sa
dernière chance on est d'accord
oui il donc du coup il entraîne les
meufs temps en temps la nôtre où sa
meilleure qu'il faille c'est probable
non mais il a dû il a du monde à vlad la
ilaha illa du poulain de très grosses
qualités mais je peux pas je peux pas
dire mais il a dû poulain qui pourrait
finir champion du monde
moi j'en connais qu'un alors c'est pas
celui que tu sais pas c'est pas le
poulet en france faire le fulleur
iranien mais c'est un autre non non non
ça russes jana qui en fait qu'est bon
ben non c'est par ce genre elle est ici
qu un coup et si c'est le cas je le
trouve quand même pas mauvais là d une
réputation internationale maintenant
très bien réputé en chine très réputé en
chine va maintenant devenir pas si
étonnante que ça parce qu'il est allé
faire en chine un match avec la gnome
j'allais dire ouais
du coup ils avaient des difficultés avec
les gars est tous très bonne réputation
chine est une très bonne réputation dans
tous les pays
kazakhstan kirghizstan ouzbékistan 1
parce que c'est chez lui d'où l'on sait
qu'il a une bonne réputation
yohji connu de patricia le fasse il a
une bonne vingtaine viennent aujourd'hui
une belle c'est ce genre de parties sont
hyper fin de toutes les parties sont
importantes mais au hangar où on est
loin
c'est le seul qui est venu en touriste
alex locaux pour moyens en dessous une
mauvaise gestion du temps mais c'est
parce qu'il veut trop bien faire mais en
gros ils sont pour moi sont des bus
était un peu un trompe l'oeil
ce qui l'est moins mais un contre digne
celle qui gagne i 1 c'est ça le trompe
l'oeil en réalité si on gagne on dîne
candy doit perdre
ouais il pourrait être à moins de 2 il y
aurait rien à dire sept îles à sion
mais ok il est il doit quand même gagné
quand guy mais bon j'ai un petit point
classement pour les gens oui bonne idée
donc mes pauses sont en tête
bon début de ton moins trois fois noir
en cinq rondes 2 propre hier grosse
pression maxime 3 dommage qu'il soit pas
trois nuits mais c'est quand même bien
caruana deux ennemis il est finalement
normal en fait parce qu'il s'en sort
presque les fesses propres rien mais les
combinats des mois il fait une mauvaise
partie
j'arrive pas à me faire un avis sur 40
ha est il joue mal dans ce moment exquis
vie pas trop mou ouais moi je le trouve
moyen aussi mais après quand tu es
moyens et que tu es là tu te réveilles
et tu gagnes quoi c'est fait c'est comme
ding ding je vois rayonnant la crise
fait notre allié le prince et guy il
trahit qu'il est bien préparé mais il
est tellement imprévisible que ça peut
je voulais autant autant hier au moins
il a été intelligent il a changé inami
médine peut revenir aussi un faux pas
l'intérêt imaginons de jingan l'epo
pendant une confrontation directe et
plus qu'à un nippon pour moi il ya
quatre joueurs qui équipent eux viennent
thomas séné poèmes vl caruana eddine
pour moi les autres grilles tous que j'y
crois pas mais gageons qu'il est pas en
forme il n'a pas envie de jouer
ouais non mais je le connais je le
connais mon ca chamond sacha quand il
démarre mal et qu'il te dit qu'il veut
plus jouer ta les gens qui écrivent sur
twitter c'est du bluff ou quoi c'est pas
du bluff sasha sa non non ça se voit il
arrête ça me dégoûte de jeu comme ça
mais je comprends il a une femme il a
des enfants à moscou on comprend pas du
tout ce qui se passe là-bas passé ils
sont comme chez nous en france
quand ça a commencé à mal tourner et je
m'attaque sommes une famille des parents
des enfants c'est normal de ne pas avoir
la tête à jouer
luongo pour moi il est lente pour lui le
compte on note là il fera des points
c'est un peu leur place du tournoi dans
bien préparé mais le preuve c'est qu'il
ya un peu naïve qui gère très mal ce
montant landes les guérillas et pleutres
non en fait non en fait sont guéris
c'est que pour moi il a un nouvel
entraîneur
je suis son entraîneur pendant six mois
je l'interdis d'animer un pc tu suis le
jour qui fait deux heures deux parties
trois ans de tactique deux heures de
finale tu vas voir qu'il va progresser
ça fait trois ans que tu penses mais
c'est sûr il a peur de tout enfin au
niveau des prépas et il a déjà il a deux
ans d'avancé tout le monde peut-être à
par magnus ils n'ont en fait le truc
c'est que quand il était jeune il était
juste bon qu'à moins cher qu'on nous dit
il est quand même très jeunes guéris
voilà il était très très fort il était
très fort et juste maintenant dès qu'il
est gagnant tout lui paraît bon du coup
ci prend jamais de bonnes décisions il
hésite trop y seront et ça c'est trop
dormir pour toi comment pour toi c'est
trop d'ordi ouais non non c'est parce
qu'en fait on a changé les cadrages sur
un truc mais pas sur l'autre donc je
viens tout recadrer et mathieu
t'inquiète pas
tu travailles tu travailles bien son
gros zoom l'apn ont désormais fait juste
que tu te mettes tête attend non non non
c'est bon je donne décalé non non non
non c'est bon c'est bon signe voilà ça
me paraît un bon format voilà comme ça
ça me paraît pas mal beau gosse merci
c'est les chemises à carreaux
sainte-flavie de ouais ouais voilà là tu
es bien parfait voilà le live officielle
pour voir les caméras temps en temps
j'aime bien qu'ils font devant les
caméras c'est quand même pas mal ce
qu'elle facturait dit que ça sert à rien
je suis pas tout à fait dans sa vie
quand tu regardes des échecs et caméras
pas les caméras ça change rien moi je
trouve que c'est quand même un vrai plus
moi je kiffe quand le même café voire la
défaite
ouais non non c'est pas indispensable
c'est pas comme au foot au tennis ou
sans les cartes jusqu'à regarder c'est
pas indispensable mais c'est un plus on
sait pas concertés pour les choses non
et j'en étais sûr j'y ai pensé comme les
mises elle c'est parti alors il a fait
débattre ou hangars aucun relief 6-4 6-4
alors attendons maintenant est ce qui va
jouer la même chose que contre j'ai
enlevé les sons des échiquiers parce que
je trouve que c'est ça fait trop de sons
après quand à tous les trucs à lui mais
non je pense qu'il a préparé une hymne
sur la vaisselle pour le tournoi oui et
non de la joie
moi je me disais ce qui va jouer le truc
aussi avec g3 un peu quand même effet
contre alex nkomé non non non je pense
qu'il va préparer une éventuelle
laquelle c'est pas faut être 4-3 samedi
dames b3 s'appelle du ni ni fous ces
quatre comme un joueur qui fait moi je
verrais plutôt foule 3 mais bon après je
peux me tromper
on va voir on va voir comment ça ça
ça se passe tac
albane échiquier ya un truc qui peut
être intéressant c'est que aujourd'hui à
l'excellent copeaux gagne je suis guéri
va vouloir vraiment gagner avec les noix
et c'est à ce job à l'italienne c'est
pas sony a donc il a joué comme caruana
fossé 4 que de très intéressant c'est la
même chose que caruana contre n'est pas
exactement
bon du coup en plus maxime joue tout le
temps de l'es6
les gens le savent s'ils ont dû mon
résumé
ouais ce que j'avais à dire si les gens
ont regardé l'émission mat
ils ont dit voir ils ont dû voir ça et
un bus que j'explique ce qu'il a perdu
deux fois sur cette ligne dans le kayak
in dans des tests de mémoire ne cache
aucun retard me l'arrivée dans ce temps
ce tournoi il est il est possible
d'arriver en retard même si on est bien
d'accord mais bon heureusement sous le
choc aurait bien besoin d'un autre côté
il serait arrivé à leurs appareils
mais d'ailleurs j'avais une question de
style à ge4s qui la préparera le cadre
pour le tournoi mais est-ce que ça
n'aurait pas tenté de jeter car pour moi
la flamme de caruana il a joué un 4gates
look je pense mais il a fait 4 n'est pas
contre eux ding espagnol donc là il a
fait rock et alex eyene kogi a italienne
alex une couche de tripoli reste 4 il
n'a pas joué d'amd d'abord il a joué
jusqu'à 34 a déjà été joué
après ces quelques affiches et ses
drôles de jouer h cup après avoir ok
nous c'est un peu bizarre mais non en
fait c'est un bizarre parce que sinon
que la dame venir soit 5
il attend la lignée eb66 tu fais h4
direct les tons ok il faut trois temps à
besoins qu'avaient laissé six essais 6
je t'attends dam des deux disons genre
ça c'est possible comme ça mais donne
tout et je suis pas sûr que j'oublie 6,5
marqué c'est juste que tu peux pas faire
h4 avant donc je vois tu peux pas trop
non oui c'est pour ça qu'en fait tu dois
faire rock est en fait b6 est pas le
seul coup mais juste c'est la main à la
mode en fait juste et donc à stadt là et
je suis quasiment sûr lui-même ou sears
1 mais où en gros pourquoi il est si mal
préparée je comprends pas en fait par
exemple la tiu contre maxime mais tu
sais que moi j'ai une élève cageux kong
a récemment elle était gagnant
rapidement dans le version sahara
c'était sahara non non deux sur trois
pas fameux conte dans tes élèves pour
les versions wii pour le heureusement
elles veulent pas m'écouter
elle travaille avec qui alors du coup je
vais parler d'un en effet à travailler
aux problèmes du nom elle nous avait
parlé d'un entraîneur qui avait beaucoup
aidé j'ai plus longtemps ouais c'est la
dernière fois qu'ils à lui un vrai
entraîneur c'était il ya six ans mais
c'était ce faire deux entraîneurs n'ont
plus qu'à compter c'est quand il était
quand elle avait pas là on a eu
plusieurs enfants à partir de 8 ans l'aï
toujours eu des entraîneurs jusqu'à
[Musique]
maintenant elle à toi quoi ouais mais là
el alem surtout joué donc cette chose
qu'on en avait déjà parlé une fois sur
la chaîne la envie de jouer donc là on
pourrait c'est frustrant je voulais voir
c'est quoi la partie l'autre jour
caruana né pauvre c'est ça ouais et h4
j'avais noté pas
il a pas de magnus et corrobore qu'à jos
a contredit j'avais vu et dogbo possible
du bonheur chez paris 9 en 2020 c'est un
coup critique à sima news si maxime l'a
pas regarder c'est une faute
professionnelle
mais à mon avis la regarder mais c'est
un peu plus mais juste une question
d'être digne du coup
il est pas mieux préparés que ça soit à
la candidate a quand même des moyens
dignes d'être c'est qu'ils jouent que
les grandes mines que l'homme je veux
dire pas dit mme par dong won je pense
qu'ils bella là il montre une prépa h4z
combien de parties gèreront en partie
dans la base mais qu au départ- récente
trois fois corrobore une fois que j'ai
par erreur fait une faute d'abord que
des malades de notre époque
donc ici il ya deux coups c'est fou j'ai
cinq wave525 tempo donc là la dame peut
venir sur 24 ça devenait très ça peut
devenir très concret du coup c'est pas
de bol silhouette à mach 4 tempo bon ça
la maxime icaunais a du coup aussi
c'était le couple joué à shanghai match
4 à greg69 3
donc il ya eu deux bornes guide l'eire
en novembre et paris nord chagaiev en
janvier du tanet et une autre partie en
janvier wereley le néerlandais contre
une guidance
il joue pas mal de chica chica y est
enfin j'ai vu pas mal de parties les
originales un f3 au tempo ouais je sais
la première partie dans cette position
yvonne choc great choc en 2012 ça quand
même pas un peu ça c'est encore ultra
théorique n'aime pas trop en fait il y a
que cinq parties
oui mais je sais pas tu dois connaître
quoi c'est le début simplement
l'allemand se connaître et avoir une
idée parce que en ce moment la balle et
un peu du côté noir
ils ont pas encore montré dans la peur
en pratique comment il faisait et moi je
n'ai aucune idée
bon c'est pas l'idée des blancs c'est
jordan des deux fous j'ai 5 et le pouget
5 et taquine et adam mouais avec la dame
repartant à je suis toile sur à cammas
est mal placée tu vois des rois f2
tourache à un moment donné quoi
[Musique]
alexandre gens prennent ils sont autour
de 8 ce qui est assez logique 1 et sur
dam des deux dames h 8 dans ma chute ce
matin
damas chute c'est un coup dur dis pas ce
que je peux veto à des 1
qu'est ce que tu as gagné 1 minute
empêchent les cinq matches joués en fait
c'était j'ai pas regardé alors dit à 28
ou b c est ce qu elle ça ça donne la
position critique qu'elle avait du vrai
une question sur walf de personnes je
peux revenir et j'ai pas le temps de
faire fou g5 à ce que je peux prendre
des quatre ici c'est trop dangereux pour
le cadenas peut-être non l'âge peuvent
la dame là j'ai des cases tapas tour 17
au coude avant puisqu'elle fougue et
cette emprise semi nomades en anglais
cavalier e 5 prend ça va aller pour les
blancs jf 600 à la baisse de 15,5 j'ai
pas un autre coup et ça une bonne can
pas encore sûr à 100% retour f8 tonin
comme que ça tombe cette girafe wef 6
intermédiaire d'un machin comme ce sens
que j'ai peint tempête
on est devant mathieu à moins d'avoir
analysé ça avant et bien sûr que ça
passe sinon ça fait extrêmement peur
mais du coup je pense à un truc
est-ce que tu joues ta machine pour lui
des foules jeu simple mais est ce que tu
en as besoin dans le sens où est ce que
faisait 5 c'est vraiment une menace si
tu fais de retrouver cette fougère 5 je
peux pas prendre des quatre dangereux
par un noyau radâmes 34 ça qu'il faut
pour qui les prend en prendre un point
je montre a du coup en fait la question
que je me pose c'est leur dire pourquoi
est ce qu'il dit que les noirs ça va
parce qu'il fait à mach 5 soit ils ont
dû analyser faut prendre des huit tours
prend des gaz moins cases noires et puis
on décape
ok c'est à dire que probablement que le
coup logique humains cfoot bessette fans
sanwi crise prises ok ça m'arrivait
monitrice pris tôt des mythes pas donné
de jeu ça ne marche pas trop d un oui
lors à vue où il aurait eu lui connaîtra
puisqu'ils ont dû analyser doctorat d un
suspense et le col ojibway qu'est ce
qu'on fait ici faut 2,5 et f4 donc je
vois pas ce qu'on gagne ça il va pas
faire tullia nakache g4 et la touche
avec ronald blanc qui s'il faut trouver
un coup utile alors avant là on menace
peut être précis texier j'avais demandé
qui jouent en coulant d'agents poursuite
ce que fout g5 marche d'un machin way we
dommages suite prise prise seul thème
bouge dans notre hockey ça a l'air
d'aller point noir il fallait un hiver
dangereux parce qu'en fait tu as la
colonne acheter ouverte et quand le faux
arrivant des cats à la force
le message rageur commune et si je suis
d'un mètre qu'adam h 2 oui j'ai trois
mois j'ai deux peut-être ça peut être
une idée un jour mais pratique des cas
très faible de plus je l'admets pas du
coup du coup comment ça marche pourquoi
est ce qu'ils écrivent dans le chat que
les trucs qui commence par ça je
souhaite à l'heure tu as dit innocent ça
que j'ai dit ça pour mon élève
ouais du court en fait si tu craques
grave non et du coup mais du coup je
regarde les parties dans la base ils
vont le show grandiose c'est peut-être
pour adé un jouet et l'autre couple a
été jouée récemment de bob c'était ton
assez 1 donc on n'a pas dit que des
conneries donc c'était plus on prend qui
on prend pour des huit thèmes des deux
roues bessette torah c'est un défaut
5arras est stratosphérique pour sa salle
est intéressant c'est de comprendre f4
faucheux cet or est roi et ses hyper
logique torreilles froid ouais mais fou
et 5 il faut dépenser 1
moi j'aime pas du tout les blés noirs
mais après bon si megan ville va vouloir
jouer cavalier à 100 est un moment
ok tu auras singe une question si je
tour site
est ce que cette fois il ya toi c'est un
tour cité des sciences genre est ce que
les électorats siens si je fais d'un
match 8 maintenant tu fais ton rêve d un
même dessein que c'est pas un coup ici
comprend pas notre idée qui des quatre
maintenant le fou est protégé à temps
mais tu m'as tu ne me lève pas de promo
et de fo décote que je refais ou 3 donc
je peux prendre le 6 et tu peux pas
prendre de cavale et j'ai pris 10 8
si je prends ici j'ai pas vu trois sets
il faut prendre de 2,9 roubaix 4 2 dans
la jambe ça je vous sajoo mature avoir
éprouvé cette année deux cdc des toits
des 8,3 cm ou 3d un jeu des 8 donc c'est
la pression c'est l'impression qu'on
inverse oui 3d en on en a parlé aussi le
tour à jean gris chaud qu'il avait le
tour 6 8 mai damages suite le code lundi
est ce un très peur de me prendre un roi
avec deux amendements c'est un rêve de
bien senti mais il y aura aidé à mach 4
[Musique]
donc on a on est un peu chier sur la
prépa 2 mondiaux mais là il place une
frappe
il connaît toujours un j'imagine
paraître assez un tempo je suis un peu
inquiet du brésilien après maxime
connais parce que quand tu joues pas un
tempo d'un match 4 tours des huit sites
à jamais
après je sais que maxime et révise avant
chaque partie des lignes critique donc
probablement bouger ça que ça marche et
non pas vraiment mais après c'est toute
analyse a lancé cheikh falah ça marche
et moins parce que prise cinq tours
prends tu peux pas jouer destin tu peux
jouer des cinq mes dessins qui est moins
fort parce qu'il ya là torrent prise
disons qu'à bâle et à 5 et tu va
regagner quelque chose sur la tour sur
la terre il faut qu'ils soient des 5 tu
va regagner trop de choses ici
d'où l'idée tour acer c'est que tu
enlèves la tour et l'idée c'est que dans
certains nîmes des cinq pour un marché
maintenant le flou sera protégé par
exemple dans cette ligne si la dame
était en âge suite est ce que je
pourrais pas jouer jusqu'à vali e et
value mais tu vois là sur parachute leur
ont alors dit de dire wife 2-1 il ya
plus d'un an jusqu'aux tchèque la
lettonie s'est quasi gagnant
je tenais à le souligner quand même
parce que c'est important
tu as our h1 chasser l'idée que
j'arrivais pas à faire marcher moi alors
dit là bas même si le faisant un geste
pour bagdad quand il fait ça revient à
temps et si tu prends là juste pour
montrer prisa mettons un juste pour
illustrer un motif et web ce même
établissement juste montrer quoi je veux
montrer au public mathieu s'est en fait
c'est une des idées que j'essayais de
faire marcher que j'arrivais pas à faire
marcher que l'ordi fait marcher donc ça
veut dire qu'après tour à ses seins
sourd à ces huit foucher 5 de la fin
qu'on est peut-être juste moins bien
d'un marché inquiet t3f 2 du coup si on
était là on a dit il faut prendre tourné
à wise oeil tandis que ça vachement bien
que ce qui prend des 4 as oui le truc
c'est que tu te rends pas sur la fuite
sur échec
il me seconder 8 donc quand tu fais là
qu'est points c'est ça la différence
j'avais compris vous prenez 800 frontaux
h1n1 c'est sacré puisqu'à plus fous il
peut il ya des cons pense non mais je
sais pas quel point de nos trois sépales
absolument pas qu'on est mieux avec les
blancs a gelé ses shows maxi va bien
jouer ça en fait je dis tout de suite il
peut faire nous n'en ait pu moi sur ce
nous plaît pas trop où elle fait la
maxime il a vraiment intérêt à se
rappeler d'un couteau ratio 1 donc on
comprend le leader phocéen qui foulent
the hockey
et si on fait d'abord je suis tout de
suite mon idée c'est que fuji sanch
prendrait quatre donc sans doute que tu
dois je tour d un maintenant tour c'est
ça me paraît plus malins comme en deux
coups et donc du coup parce que wave 2
j'ai toujours d'un match 4 donc ici faut
regarder fou g5 probablement au d5 c'est
le deux coups logique faux g5 comprend
des quatre secondes vous prendre des
huit ouais mais ça je pense que dès
qu'on pense comme tu dit maxime il a
bien aimé ça pourquoi tu prends il
menaçait pas prendre et c'est surtout
des 4 1 1
voyez cette âme de food et 4,3 f1 dans
la charrette
non mais là tu as lu ce tronçon de tout
reprendre et cut
je vous prends là dedans tout point non
et donc ça c'était une idée je reprends
du fou fou desquels je prends de la tour
et la fin des tours 7
après peut-être que ça fait quand même
nul pour des deux mains tour des deux
rois f2 ça tu fais pas nul non par wave
ii ya fouet
enfermé en fait je foulais 5 il faut
l'aimer c'est vraiment pas de chance
pour moi quand même c'est vrai davos est
d'accord donc en vente son essai de
comparer avec l'autre jour les blancs
l'arrivée d'avoir poussé le pion à
jetons qu'ils devraient attendre plus
sauf qu'au lieu d'avoir joué à chier si
la joie qu'on veut c'est intéressant de
comparer ouais
ces deux approches différentes de celles
de cette idée de pousser les pions h
en fait l'idée d'un match 4 ces deux
d'empêcher l'empêcher alors pourquoi ça
l'empêché regard c'est une question a
longtemps empêché juste physiquement et
le deuil n'était pas encore en d2 il n'y
a pas de g3 nouilles à damas trois ya
sept cadeau qui en fait il a perdu un
temps fort sage et à salles assez
intéressant nordiques ou dessin doit pas
être une idée jeunes cavaliers pour les
sourds à 5 ou et après le plan b 5 est
faible en a pas des six donc ça c'est
trop rapide trop trop trop rapide six
foulées saint cloud et 6 probable
il échange plutôt solide poindre comme
ça et les gens aiment ça donne le tour
c'est 8 3e set j'aurais été mieux si
juste que et merci merci à fait fenris
saga pour le sun
merci tonton j'ai juste à savoir i
sulley en fait de le fou noir me saoule
en fait atteint revient donc revient
quelques idées ce que les lieux ne
saperait pas de menottes des cinq bof
web de boeuf ait un lien ou quelqu'un
d'un chat à vous et j'ai trois rangées
de tout à l'heure je te prends pour ses
8 ou un g2 je crois toujours à chaque
fois ci ce genre sans que tu arriveras
jamais quand ça s'arrête finlande et 4
complètement faux mouais
les libye qui déconne au château libye
aya libye fatah mouche à merde et je
relance pas à chaque fois recul et re
écran noir tant pis je l'air et le
replay value pas laisser de choper sur
youtube mais bon ils vont pas nous en
arrivons pas nous entendre parce qu'ils
peuvent à nous voir pourquoi tu sais que
j'ai reçu un mail hier de twitch dans la
nuit par cette nuit et ils m'ont dit
qu'ils allaient baisser les en fait ils
peuvent plus voir le l'estrimont super
hd ou je sais pas quoi
ah oui best ou netflix my canal tous
horizons baisser donc va savoir ce à
cause de ça pour certaines personnes du
coup ça a créé un blog j'en sais rien
ok tour ces huit là se trouve un plan
pour les blancs dans l'être j'aime bien
la position blanche mais en fait je ne
sais pas pourquoi tu dois jouer ce jeu
pour eux cinq dans l'absolu met un
cavalier sur 24 ça paraît fort mais ça
pareil genre hyper lent de prendre moi
je n'aime pas du tout ça pour les blancs
au contraire j'ai l'impression que mon
pions des quatre il est cloué que je
vais faire contre attaquer un jour par
la gauche ou par la droite et je me sens
super mal peut pas mettre ta dam soulève
deux voyages au thorax et 8 sur
quasiment sûr demain pour éviter les
cavaliers ou cinq cavaliers à 5 mg dl il
adore ce en général et noir j'ai jamais
trop compris me sens bien je trouvais
cinq à six coups des francs à dire
marquer son nom j'aime bien
jamais notre en fait c'est quand tu
écris nord c'est aussi déplaisante kf5
savent pas l'air d'être une idée de ouf
la case à case de plonger le système le
5 là tu me laisserais descente que jouer
son jeu pour tous les cinq dames à 3 ghz
et 4 9 et 5 kgs en prison mais je pense
que c'est tu vas du mauvais côté d'un
match 4 à faire 4 je vais te planter un
live de d'un holding
je sais pas quand tu as la tour des huit
entreprises du temps je pense juste que
c'est pas simple parce que t'as pas
grand chose à faire donc demain je
trouve ça de cavaliers à 5,6 en fait je
veux pas d'autre kung fu b 5 à 6 ou deux
points vous trouvez une idée c est ce
qui peut pas faire comme dépôt tout est
changé pour prend son rang dans ce mythe
tôt reprend 3 ok maintenant faut
réfléchir comment on joue au centre la
structure ses petits avantages blanc
mais les mecs le plan insiste comme
forest plus peur se vendent pas avoir
peur pour les noirs en fait non non non
plus l'un et du coup est-ce que je peux
pas garder le tour aux coudes à domjean
retour b18 on attaque là on commence à
faire sa d'un quart des 4 b 5 c'est pour
ça que tu es venu en début d'accord
section 5 et 6 4
j'ai dit mon idée quoi non mesdames mais
coach jean-michel caye ces quatre
attaques et b6 je tiens ces coûts mais
la loi protège le cas ben en fait
c'était pas vraiment l'idée sur la b4
c'est l'idée juste de pouce est inquiet
londonderry c'est la balle et c'est un
petit tour ont fait un petit tour donc
d'avoir peut-être mais maxime a l'air
plutôt bonne ouverture ailleurs il a agi
correctement et en asie donc sanitaire
est classé au rang 1
ça sent quand la théorie tu crois ouais
après alex normalement joue pas à 4 il
aime bien ne pas jouer à que non ils
aiment bien je compterai il a mis à 4 à
5 tout de suite donc à cinq on en a vu
pas mal avec toutes les parties de
d'accord en ce pitch s amène à came et
elles font de belles 6 to
oui mais fois sa théorie possible bien
sûr ouais ça je suis censé connaître un
peu il ya pas mal parti de maxime là
quand il avait battu d'abord à
d'ailleurs bompas mais abaisse de très
intéressant great choc contre caruana
appartient importante pour les deux
hommes assez la dernière principaux mais
non au cnda zone poussiéreuse où il a
bâti notre maxime ouais donc grise ou
que ne peut pas être complètement
surpris ils rejouent la ronde à amy la
chose il n'a pas pris un des quatre îles
à peu près des côtes et les jeux
tournent donc que ce sont entre maxime
il avait fait le way non grippés 4 15 et
4 encaissés 3 de monsieur cet accord
oblige equity le budget 5 au lieu de
huit
c'est la nouveauté donc il est là je
t'aurais 8 dont encore une fois ce que
j'expliquais dans la vidéo ici
le cool plus je sens faut trop c'était
pour à 8 parce que des princes 1 qui
était censée être une menace dont
comment ma question c'est après tours 8
je prends comme ça c'est sa prépa long
coup franc ont validé juste que tu
montes scipion prend 1,5 si tu reprends
bêtement je prends des huit de la tour
je prends à cet égard 35e jean-claude
peu après foxes commande est champion à
90 continue la ligne juste trop bas ou
kung fu six prises aux six prises aussi
on a eu quatre ans prises monde de fond
tech3 moto2 tu rentres pas put empêche
le cavalier de sortir en c6 cinq ans
noyé dans un hangar donc faux 3-1 [ __ ]
donc si on prend 1,5 il peut pas premier
qui avait donc ce coup c'est fou prend
1,3 j'en prends m6 c'est la seule idée
est donc il a préparé sa en corian mais
fade ouf on sent encore une prépa blanc
sait pas où il a prévu de mettre le fond
il ya à chis à cet indicateur est assez
simple c'est 5 c'est bizarre je veux
toujours faire la guerre qui allait dam
des 5 alors migré tous qu'il est rentré
là dedans on va juste pour voir
meyrannes ont épaté en fait il a fait kg
la répétition
pourvu qu'elle soit aurait taille
puisqu'il se dit qu'il va il faut garder
ce fou déjà mal autant en fait ouais
mais c'est bien je dois botter un coup
oui oui là il a rajouté deux coups en
fait
ok donc quand on prend un cinglant il
est sûr est ici que progressant de celle
qu hélas il a juste peur de l'après par
ceux du coup si tu dois jouer tous les
deux ça veut dire que tu as économiser
entre mi mai
3,8 ou je peux prendre des catéchistes
et bkt jouer le truc normal et c'est une
lecavalier pas venue est pas venu sur
ces trois comme dans la partie
précédente
je vais je vis de québec a trouvé cette
c5 c3 et ça et bien ça peut arriver dans
des lignes les mecs à l'appel de fo 3-1
ici siphon toro 1-1 clés noires on fait
ça en fait on fait tout ruiz ashes to b
7 et on joue plus on prend des cats on
joue seule position avec le faux trois
cadets 2 il ya des partis comme sa
récente et en bas de la tour 1 c'est un
peu une perte de temps lors de combats
l'un pour menacer de prendre les 5
mais là car on a tout dit non en fait
c'est pas une menace nazie puis reprend
1,5 si on va essayer d essayer de
comprendre
on va jouer un peu les coûts on va mais
le redis pour tricher un peu fourre se
veut pas qu'elle est plus logique
paraissait le comprendre d'amd 5,5 et
pourquoi faut aussi s'il ne mentionne
landes hip hop à une fougue et royan
prise oif teint d'accord
mam est ont trouvé cinq jamais non forez
4 sera fier bien placé mais pourquoi tu
as repris vous on peut voir beaucoup
d'avancé peut pas aller sur une case
plus actives sans ses six premiers il
fut promu et trois caïds et trois dames
m6 a l'air d'aller pour le noir comme
c'est visuellement c'est bizarre en mai
à notre c4 taton tkv ça si tu as passé
ta pas fait alors dit tu es tu veux
jamais dans une question est-ce que je
peux tenter d'en prendre six on a comme
une pièce dans ce crime alors attend à
lyon prend fou prend pions prends mon
faut être 400 milliards contente qu'elle
5 qu'elle valait prend faut aussi donc
sinon vous ferez d'en prendre six ya
comme une pièce que tu prend du plomb et
half a été prise donc je raconte de la
tour ici si ce qu'elle est c'est 6
fourchette dames 8 quai branly et 8 à
béton dame prend des points même si je
tombais son sahara et mettons ça juste
pour conter caisse et deux tourelles ça
a l'air d'aller pour les noires les
points noirs le teint raison comment
j'allais dire peut-être ton problème si
ce projet ici c'est trouver du jeu sur
le voir ce que lecavalier au bois et
prend 1 6 3 6 et dames c8 et peut-être
que c'est nul
la dame le cadre déjà bonjour nous
l'atakor été alimenté bien des arrières
mais d'un autre côté tu as beaucoup de
jeu quoi celui-ci aurait donc d'en
prendre six pas si fort
c'est fou quand même les prépas de
caruana j'ai pas nos stages cemac et la
moustache alors attends je vais juste
mettre une petite bulle chaix chasse
cogne il m'a dit ils m'ont dit à toutes
les demi-heures une pub quoi pupu pub
quoi parce qu'ils ont réalisé
écoute je vais suivre les directives 1
je vais réunir des mortels chez le 3 oui
là je sors assez vite maximin donc bien
jouer d'un de cette nouveauté il évite
les merdes tactique la table préparée du
midi salle open le premier coup tu leur
dis mais c'est un coup logique solide
mais fait tour à ses 8 ans non mais ça
va maximin je m'inquiète pas du tout
mais ça me va ça a l'air d'être un
taureau 8-6 a déjà été joué les
bichiques en bois dans le pied en 2003 à
cette loi
je me prends m6 il avait je fous à chis
je me prends g7 et les demi finales au
maroc où ça s'est moins libye les prépas
de bonneuil pidy le dude en action
chaque femme était juste mal il à la
partie sale 2006 il avait les blancs
robe
ils ont fait nul en fait c'est bizarre
qu'il n'ait pas tenté d'emmener 5 m sur
6 ha dans l'absolu c'est que c'est le
couple descend ce faire fortis d'un
processus où prend b3 d'un prend 1,6
smic et leur dit que c'est quand même
assez gagnant pour les blancs ouais mais
après un pratique dit pas je me fais
enfermer n'y a pas un perpétuel fou
qu'on peut bien pousser huit dames ceci
je vois passer par des simples mais du
coup faut être quatre ça change quoi là
ceci c'est hyper intéressant encore vous
venez caruana c'est quand même au niveau
d'affilée au dessus
c'est incroyable ça lasse mal gens qui
sont présentés chez moi bah oui mais
donc comme on disait c'est probablement
aujourd'hui peut y avoir des problèmes
pour la cause de à cause des changements
qu'ils ont dû faire pour la mon avis la
plateforme twitch pour l'heure pour le
débat peut prendre le nul n'a pas tort
non par principe trop pleutres kazim
au-dessus baisse pour croire franchement
bien plus c'est pas un mec comme adam ce
qui va arriver avec autant de nouveautés
dans les ouvertures du coup hangar où il
a joué mon cou coiffe ou g5
ouais faut aussi s'il va échanger sa
faire revenir si débile non quel coût
c'est rigolo f4 up cela peut être un
coup dordives part à temps et a fait
froid et systèmes pos ouais être 4 cdma
connaissez peut-être qu'avec elles sont
bons mais là ça va ça va c'est changer
ça va faire du nul rapide non je sais
pas j'espère pour moi ait eu à dire pour
le résumer après run et cinq cavaliers à
pas fou regarde et dessins qui ont
notamment regardé par 2 3 c'est
exactement ce qu'on a et regarder mais
ça avait l'air d'être assez atypique
droit g7 et non je regardais vas-y des 5
il ajouta me 3,3 g 7 ans était le coup
logique pour moi kiev 4
pour un jeu suit règles comment ça m'a
fait bien de faire doubler ça me doubler
dans l'agrégat m4 g3 c'est con mais
regarde j'ai pas trop et mère je trouve
que tu vas garder des pions comme ça
face aux fous rires ouais f2 désireux de
ce que dan scott je peux faire cailler
de trop même damages cas de l'asie
s'intéresse ceci je fais tout rechange
je peux peut-être un peu mieux un mai
2006 leur attaque live surtout rachat
dame prend les cartes
ok je faire curieux 2 mais je pense que
ça va vraiment faire nul à mathieu
possible le truc c'est que les blancs
jouent là pacory mettre la marche avec
option d les rois sont à peu près autant
aussi faible à 1 kl autres et si tu
commences à vouloir avancer ta position
tu vas te faire contrer c'est clair et à
ok moi j'ai une question si tu fais
cavaliers à 5
imaginons que je jouais la collection à
cassis foot est roi
je suis pas sûr qu'à 6 soit un bon coup
dans l'absolu je viens plutôt non
maintenant parce que la foulée siens qui
tapait plus aidé en rien entre eux les
72 comprends c'est injuste de jus de
voir ça les tours s'est vite
est ce qu'on est vraiment moins bien
qu'à ses trois des cinq hommes il a fait
l'autre jour peut-être un petit quelque
chose là bas c'est un petit quelque
chose mais du coup je préfère la prépa
de karwan à d'abord mis le pion à 1,6 me
paraît plus dérangeant pour les blancs
études avoir la partie contre n'est pas
nouvelle à roye j'essaie de fait c'est
hyper leroy g7 on va essayer de
réfléchir entre nous alors des cinq
cavaliers afin qu'en général on fait et
après on prend des cinq je vois pas ce
qu'on en fait je vois pas une idée le
fou bessette est bien placé tout est
bien perso ça me les pommes on n'a pas
le temps de faire le cinq des six est
une idée revient g4
c'est du coup dont je te parlais mais ça
va être inquiétant non je vais changer
cinq doivent être fixés sur quasiment
tous rage suis 3g 2 je suis dans les
temps d'un match katia tour h
je suis d'accord que les noirs peuvent
le g5
non y'a kg 3-6 melaga kg entre autres
avec trop tard ouais ouais si je voulais
faire les deux ont la même idée à
bâtonnets d'encre wager cette jaquette
c'est une idée 5 peut-être seul coup
maintenant des cinq mais je suis pas sûr
qu'on soit si content à moins que les
guettent
parce que même que je comprends pas
comment ça marche ou ça ne marche pas du
tout en demeurant et à la fin aya b5 là
à tomber un ton bien mars contre clouage
option français ça se continue encore
selon de lune tout reprend ce trois
jours et on entend des influx logique
pour les signes 37e et ça c'est mieux
pour elles c'est beaucoup mais pour les
blancs pas forcément gagner une guenon
ce tour 7 3 qui peut pas prendre à faire
c'est trouver 3 pour ses huîtres ait eu
6 2 non mais là on est de défendre et
non sinon c'est pas si simple
nous n'avons pas joué caïds et 4 si tu
peux qui a des qualités que tu recules
l'enlaidir g4 à la tête d'un bon coup
nancy turku vrai lorsque les banyala
[Musique]
51,4 g5 peut-être sont dotés d'un
monsieur dessous des 3 es là tu vas
commencer à pouvoir faire ça ça c'est
mieux pour les blancs et les noirs
qu'ils arrivent ne sait pas encore que
l'info qui bougent leur four mais la vie
alors comment je ne sais pas pour jeter
bessette pour avoir la casse et sans que
la case de six à huit c'est un peu moche
mais stratégiquement c'est logique c'est
vrai que c'est moche comme coup tu
laisses x 600 fusent des fois comment tu
peux arriver à m
bouvet ce fou peut-être même parfois six
direct tv c'est de bouffer le prononcer
maintenant
ouais mais ça valait ou pouvant ainsi sa
savane je pense aux airs x 8 juin enfin
je mettais g3 et que j'essaie de penser
qu'elle a fait 4 alors scorpions prend 2
me prend la mecque et fois ci c'était
too much mais on en a un c'est un peu
too much of x 8 c'était comme si qu'un
france et un habitant français un jeu
que je fous ces huit noms jetés mais
c'est un orage suite écrit p 7
merci s'appelle régaler mais je pense
que f4 c'est toujours le coup à regarder
dans ces pays sous le nom parce que f5
c'est peut-être vraiment une idée on est
prêt pour faire ici c'est enfermer les
noirs on prend il ya dam des quatre qui
gagne peut-être direct saint ouen
annonciades un projet sein même de m6
web comme ça j'aime pas trop vieux
dangereux ça n'est il pas dangereux
donc on fait ça donc j'ai quatre salles
est le bon coup et qui dit si tu fais le
5 e te fais g5 et je joue pour être 4
way et dont carnatique leroy g7 ça peut
paraître beaucoup mais là tu te rends
compte qu alger cap ça peut faire chier
parce que tu vois pas de plan ouais en
fait ce qui est important juste pour
bien expliquer c'est que deux bases
mathieu il avait deux plans de fer f4
pour avancer et à jouer du des 5 ou 10 e
simple quand même du f 5
mais le truc c'est que ça affaiblit
c'est trop la diagonale blanche et le
roi blanc pouvaient se retrouver en
danger et g4 l'avantagent côté blanc
c'est que ça permet de garder le mur
contre le fu hu est la cerise notre ou
en fait bizarrement way puisqu'on fait
rage et de tours h1 et on contrôle la
colonnade l'on peut se faire rentrer
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai quatre ça
fait autant sens et tu veux faire g5
pour aller taquiner les cases noires
autour du roi et réseauter un peu le roi
donc c'est pour ça que c'est très
logique en réalité ce que ce que propose
mathieu
et du courage et 7 qui est un coup très
logique de base pour faire tout rage
suite éventuellement et se placer ses
envies de la diagonale du fou et placer
ses pièces n'étaient pas si bons
il y en a plusieurs qui ont un problème
on est désolé les gars ça vient pas nous
ça vient d'eux de tous les hébergeurs de
stream qui qui baissent les délits il ya
des problèmes visiblement oui j'ai
quatre tours à je suis tu veux jouer hg
5,3 g 2 je sais pas quel est le but
logique 3g 2 parce que damages quatre
tours h ans arrêté dans le tempo et tu
te garde g5
il fait ici un petit qu'en fait il faut
trouver un plan avec les noirs c'est
toujours le attend ici tu fait cavalier
à simple maintenant des trois sont
français et un d'un masque est empêchée
tour à shanghai
mais en fait c'est que un échange si je
fais de 9,4 à peu et chacun age 2 et
laly finale vont être mauvaise parce que
tu as tord 6,7 à la fin il ya le
cavalier mvvm leroy jeu 3-3 le nom j'ai
trop attaqué le tour je poursuis forcé
sur ces 7
mais ces finales allait commencer à être
moins bien moins bien 3 je le répète
laurent aux trois quarts à dakar annonce
de 12,73 où les blancs sont un peu mieux
ce vraiment pour moi je suis roi g7 les
maxima par le roi g7
c'est peut-être une erreur moi j'essaie
de ça nous paraissait logique
ouais écoute et b les photos de scènes
360 tonnes est-ce que vous avez vu
ouais c'est pour les gens fous qui s'il
a du mal à voir faut baisser la
résolution et c'est pour ça c'est juste
les hébergeurs internet qui
pas léser les provider internet qui
baissent les débits partout pour que
porté par un collapse donc je pense que
c'est pour ça que vous avez des
problèmes aujourd'hui et comme je dis
j'ai reçu un mail hier de twitch qui
expliquait sa fin qui expliquait pas
comment faire mais qui nous disaient
voilà suite suite à la crise sanitaire
beaucoup trop de gens sur internet et
pour pour s'assurer que qu'on est tous à
internet et ça continue à marchande
obligé de faire ça je veux un scoop un
scoop sur la partie de kahone a gelé se
tourner le lait la sempa mon mail et là
dessus sur le porter sur qui on prend
1,5
nous prendrons n'avait pas dit de
conneries comprend des mots être quatre
cinq ou d'amd 5 donc cabello 5 et j'ai
mis un autre coup tout rocistes proposé
par mail et là tu en prends g7 à l'idée
c'est que si tu fais dame prend je fais
des cinq dans un chai faut que ça
devienne adams et ça donc tu fais plus
proche 200ç ces dames e set et là tout
peut en réalité c'est qu'on veut bouger
la tour on a défendu à vii et le jeu
tanger sisto rachid sahara plus que ce
dont parlait yannick hier avec les à 5
tours à cela et la c1 sur lift que j'ai
jamais vu quand même donc ce serait ça
l'idée grâce à ou cabello s'annonçait
pas mais il réussit c'est hyper dur à
voir
ouais c'est même possible que certains
sont aussi parce que c'est vraiment dur
à voir se souvient de l'effet un petit
collégien verser ma pensée qui veut
jouer cabariot c'est pas grand chose
mais en fait il peut rester reste y est
question dans cette ligne ouais
bon du coup à nespouls n'a pas vu ou par
l'enseigné powell j'en profite pour me
retrouver dans le cosi je passe
rapidement je jette un oeil maxime
sapajou et maxime qui réfléchit quand
est ce que tu penses que ding peut
encore être dans la prépa non nous ou en
gare ou pardon je les confonds dedans
c'est possible parce qu'ils jouent gamme
assez vite à un gang et on me disait
tout à l'heure aussi dans le chat qui a
maintenant pas mal de joueurs qui
voudraient reporter le tournoi est à
l'origine qu'un bail avant garde jacques
voulait pas de jouer ya greenbook
entourage
tu auras deux seuls grands coups et donc
radjabov ça fait quand même trois sur
huit même si radiographie n'est pas venu
donc ça c'est ouais ça fait partie de
mes analyses encore 1 16 moi j'ai
toujours pensé que c'était un tout petit
peu mieux pour les blancs mais jouable
toute façon je pense pas que ce soit
aujourd'hui que les peaux prennent des
risques mais pose c'est plus un joueur
qui peut faire mal à des guiry
d'ailleurs il a battu à des rixes et
ienco les grands nîmes éventuellement à
des mangas ou de battre tout le monde
ouais mais je veux dire par là que
peut-être sa bonne stratégie c'est
d'essayer de faire quatre nuls contre
ding et caruana s'il y arrive pour lui à
mon avis c'est mieux de faire face il
fait 2 sur 4 contre ces gars-là c'est
bien ce que je pense c'est qu'elle est
un joueur qui peut s'envoyer en l'air et
qui a plus de marge contre à hangzhou un
alex nko'o guéri j'ai du mal à voir un
gi battre un dépôt par exemple tu vois
ce que je veux dire il ya un problème et
je pense que dans les styles
correspondance c'est pas idiot pour
dépôt d'essayer de jouer un truc
tranquille ouais mais en fait funding
dans tous les cas très dur de le
brusquer comme vous qu'il a jeté ses 3,3
cologie donkey la parole du fouquet's kg
ce que j'avais écrit remédier si tu
pouvais transposer dans la partie contre
maxime il veut pas donc il a joué un
truc qui joue le sauf que dépôt est
encore très bien préparé que moi j'ai
toujours pensé que c'était un peu mieux
que dans cette position qu'il ya le
foucades mois au meeting a déjà montré
plusieurs fois que ils sont de garde et
se fourrer dans cette ligne 1 je peins
cas j'ai envie de te dire
phosagro fait la diff quand même un
arrière de 20 millions d'euros
c'est ça la motivation du joueur parce
que c'est que de bas ça devrait aller
pour gris
ou que le fossat gros non pas au courant
n'a pas eu d'écho
non mais c'est parce qu'ils demandent
plein de conditions avant d'être
sponsorisé critiques d'être sûr de pas
être objet dire du bien de la mare ou ce
genre de choses c'est que youtube quoi
donc du coup il on préfère prendre les
plus cons dommage pour la course h
tripoli fait ce que sur ordinateur
portable si t'as pas une carte graphique
performante ça sert à rien il a ça donne
des idées aux mais dans tous les cas ça
quelques mal ça fait des gaffes mais ça
donne les y aider non parce que même moi
j'ai une carte graphique est très bonne
et il n'y a pas une énorme différence
mais bon hein
pour mieux faire sur importations un
fixe mais comme pour tout aux stocks
fiche sur le fix it ont dix fois plus
vite donc donc on peut rester peut-être
un peu on va où on revient un peu sur
maxime on discute un peu avec le chat là
on a un petit temps mort vitalic sinko
fait beau alors est-ce que c'est pas la
première fois que guiry n'est pas
beaucoup mieux au temps c'est pas faux
et donc du coup on peut pas prendre le
simple ce qui est deux qui traînent
saint pry cerise fraise 2 me faut
toujours le montrer sur utile classique
à salir le marché double attaque donc
donc quels sont les coups possibles pour
le long des 4 mai des quêtes j'aime bien
et noir en général je peux prendre
et lorsque je vais les prendre et je
vais laisser mon fou en prison dams et 7
il ya une partie de fraises comme ça il
agit comme si cette tour à 8 et tu t'en
es si prends tu reprends et tu veux mais
quasiment gagnante au dessus de son
attrait de sur le x 4 est complètement
en jeu donc ça doit être solide bh3 ça
nous paraissait un peu mou c'est vrai
que c'est un peu bizarre ans pressurage
trois mois après peut-être que le après
le dit le premier spectacle sur des
katja projet cas ça doit être solide
la rivière voyage est fou c2c de hockey
bon moi je ferais d'homs et sept mois
ce que la dame toujours servir sur la
diagonale avec le kg 3 qui peut être en
prise
jeffrey dame ses sept tours à huit et je
jouais pour f5 et envoie moi je préfère
les noirs déjà mes veines les sauces et
que les à moins qu'ils kg 5 mai kg 5 je
peux laisser peut-être les dames c'est 7
pourrait voler et g5 est-ce que je peux
je veux je peux le laisser tora à 8 sa
prochaine prendre un camion à 4 et
surtout reprend j'ai pas envie hockey
dans quel dessein je fais juste fou 17
ailleurs quatre cas sur cinq avait le 14
il ya du jeu mais pas ceux où je vais
pas trop envie de te [ __ ] 17 mais j'en
crois les noirs seraient pas mieux ce
qu'ils ont ou qui brille ils ont
centrale puisse avancer alors je sais
que parfois ça peut être un peu étonné
des faits il peut y avoir des d'un
machin cabaye à un matt obscures tout le
dos le vois pas ma réaction
au pire un là je regardais des cats mais
j'arrive pas chiante rang et sacs et
sacrifices les gens voient ça va falloir
marcher du tout donc du coup et je ferai
dame 100 7 sauf que la dame aime bien
aller bien sûr cette case protège à son
potage aux 5
elle t'a par p g iii mais j'aimais
l'idée de ramener l'autre effet rennes 5
c'est vrai que siguiri gagnent 6 schiste
on essaye de page ou artistiques et g5
marche pas berne n'est pas obligé de
jouer à chis ça c'est le genre de petits
trucs qu'on gagne juste un tempo des
fois est ce que tu penses que siguiri un
jour ce n'est à se réveiller a commencé
à gagner ses positions gagnantes il
serait pas juste numéro deux mondial
claire forêt de scissy comptes rené peau
admettons il perd pas fait qu'elle peut
obliger de perdu sa prépa de vous et qui
bayer caruana il sera plus un et ce
serait pas jusque là ce serait pas volé
du tout en fait non mais ne me faites
sont coincés qu'il est juste plus
faibles aux échecs mais il joue moins
bien qu'avant ces cas là il est trop
ordinateurs de l'agresser
ça a joué mais c'est logique hein mais
du coup j'ai quatre pour moi c'est un
vrai test
et j'imagine que le redis va dire que ça
va mais pour un humain g45 jeu roi g2g 5
et de jouer sur les cases noires ok on
ans cavalier p4 est à 5 serait pas une
idée pour bien installer le carélien b4
ont déjà tu veux te fait roi
et deuxièmement son cavalier en b 4 il
n'est pas non plus très impressionnant
mais sam non mais ça peut être
intéressant imaginons dans la tuque
jouer des coudes et byd genre à 5 à 4
ouais ben jor je joue en fait j'ai
quatre comme le voulait jo quebecers
pour montrer aux caisses et jolie
maintenant je fais j'ai 5
je continue mon plan wager 2 ou d'un
mètre quatre peut-être empêché le st
alors je vais te regarde ton cavaliers
il est joli mais en quoi il qu'est ce
qu'il fait en fait rien il fait plein il
fait pas faisant ce qu'il fait pas assez
trop d'ordinateurs ça veut dire quoi ses
gambettes je pense qu'il a c'est
quelqu'un d hyper travailleurs de qui
travaille avec l'ordi bam bam et le
bronze c'est que maintenant quand son
échiquier mais il doit réfléchir par lui
même et j'ai l'impression qu'il y arrive
plus s'ils jouaient mieux avant
normalement il était invaincu contre car
c'est ni l'été 2008 il avait 18 ans et
maintenant ils et 27,50 vent dans le dos
il ya une plus une partie et il a 20 ans
oui il est trop scolaire wife de jouer
tempo paraguay 2-2 on avait vu qui avait
nulle d'un match 4 et générant trois
2006 parce que pourquoi nul parce que
eux cinq ici pour montrer aux gens dans
ma démarche de sectorisation dame 34 il
n'y a pas d'âme à chips qui a le courage
c'est ça du coup damage catch attack des
cadres qu'est-ce que du coup l'idée
droit f2 c'est pas 2 mois ci une
proposition nul parce que sinon après
pour h&m et blanc peuvent être un peu
mieux ce qui est même pas sûr mais c'est
marrant comme encore il a tellement pas
envie de jouer ce tournoi c'est fou non
après
[Musique]
iris est une moto [ __ ] en mobylette dit
guéri c'est un élève qui a français le
sont par coeur mais qui ne comprend pas
ce qu'il apprend et je sais pas il a
donc besoin d'un mec et top 10 mondial 1
on parle quand même d'un mec qui
vraiment il ya quatre ans pour moi
pouvait être celui qui gênait carlson
fin il était en balance et elle seule
qui dès qu'ils avaient battue qui
témoigne non mais il a régressé il a
vraiment juste régressé ces cinq avec
levier et dans le jeu pour lui tout est
compliqué et en fait il a ma vie d'être
aux jeux avec leur ville il sait faire
un hacker trop de positions du coup la
peur de tout il a fait trop d'ordi là tu
penses que ça a vraiment faim jamais
guéri c'est pas le 6 le plus fort moyen
mais c'était un très bon joueur pour ça
dommage qu en ce moment une aide humaine
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un ami
ou pas ou tu le connais pas plus que ça
moi il m'a énervé une fois je ne
connaissais pas on se disait bonjour
mais je ne connaissais pas et de vendée
- j'ai dit en parlant de moins il sait
que je ne me voit et me dit il n'aurait
pas perdu du poids
henri gault et après ils sont vraiment
en rigolant je dis tu as un problème
il a fermé sa gueule il dit quand il ya
deux et trois jours à cancale que je
veux apprendre à jouer ensemble dans le
tourment et par contre on analyse et
louis une grande de danse à me connaître
les gens mais il fait pas genre à mettre
50 et 25 kilos en plus ici mais après il
est dit en rigolant sur une digue d'un
proche les îles situées encore lui ne va
pas durer très longtemps non non non pas
du tout oui fallait leur site est d un
peu violent fatwa six lycéens karpatchev
par exemple dans ce quartier qui se
rendre compte que il peut pas le dire
est qu'ils chambre - karpatchev du coup
oui mais non mais c'est un ours
karpatchev charge anti en vrai mais d'un
match qu est ce qui peut vous préparer
wife 1 avec des machins qui est bel et
bien je suis sûr que non non on peut
regarder peut-être situer
chef qui ne peut pas perdre du poids il
excelle karpatchev c'est le temps je
n'ai pas vu d'ailleurs il est bien plus
trop en france avant de jouer les open
mais l'âge reste était l'open de cannes
mais n'était pas très content je puis
pourquoi n'ont-ils bien plus trop payer
plus si j'atteins karpatchev par avance
1 il ya eu des bagarres dans les
tournois ça devait arriver
il ya une bagarre avec ya pas une bague
avec les arméniens dans les olympiades
avec avec aronian et c'est la copine
d'un run yonne avec caen gorman il a way
home est anglais il est un gay sa copine
d'ailleurs j'espère t va bien je sais
pas ce que tu as vu de news je crois car
elle est mieux non 5 malgré la météo en
état grave
pour la peine non mais j'avais vu dans
ma région il ya un mec qui dirait
chaumereuil l'abbé mines droite bien sûr
des pièces de tous les échiquiers
c'est beau non je suis pas qui c'est
mais peut-être qu'ils regardent ça
manque un peu nan parfois ouais après
ces faits suspects oui du coup
proposition nul implicite mais après je
me dis il faut juste trouver un match 4
kg 3 et 6 e 5 ça fait quand même peur à
première vue oui mais si f 5 cavaliers
cette vase y revient le cinq noms de 9,6
de même 6 e 5 d'un match 4 4 je faisais
au cavalier seul tout le monde j'ai pas
vu je comprends toujours pas le mc el
eulma qui prendra pas trop de risques en
maxi est juste du coup f5 après damage 4
kg 3 est ce que c'est un coup d'une
menace f4f 4
prise 3 et qui est sain de ce qui attend
à moins de trois champs et pensent
écarté chèque dans mon roi va s'échapper
par des sports devra je suis de tout
coeur à six chèques pendant deux heures
dans ma tête j'étais déjà tout rachète
saônois un ses échecs
ok en cave cinq mois tu peux pas jouer
quand tu veux parler de 4 battu 6-7 uvf
kf4 toi jéjé 5 c'est un coup ben ouais
c'est chaud il peut la perdre un garrot
en vraie love soumettre leurs biens on
va mettre un petit pont avant l'ordi f5
se fait quoi il te fait d'annoncer trois
donc mais lastours h1 et d'hommes c'est
3 j ai pas pensé parce que vous voyez
avec et veiller à saint-cloud attendait
la sueur f4 fait comment il fait des
cinq 5 des français 6 ok mais du coup ça
fait juste un échange
ouais donc cavalia 5
il te fait des cinq échecs d'un même si
ce n'est du coup maxime et peugeot ça
parce que les finales nba dans sonic et
noah qui peuvent être le nom pour
française f 4g 5
je vais commencer à prises des 5 g 5
décembre
peut-être pas un enjeu 5 gt vallat le
poncho les fragilise également à je peux
pas le prendre il a tourné un mécène war
2 5 pouces dans ton décès titubait elle
a dû les stores sat ouais tu pousses à
des nuls mais oui c'est hip hop
pressurisée a donc ok mais d'un match 4
ce qui n'a pas prévu roi défense des
peuples amérindiens sont encore plus mal
maintenant je pense qu'il va jouer sa
nokia hockey des cinq vas-y fkk cinq
dames des quatre 2006 et il ya un
problème parce qu'on peut menacer des
fois ci il faut b3 tour c'est un k-way
janvier chat parce qu'on a réalisé à
fond pour nous faire une première ligne
de la tourbe une profondeur 30
ça prouve que quelques 300 de marche
alors mais elle est bizarre c'est réparé
de brandao rires oui en fait d'un mot
soldes suis sûr que c'est pas ça va pas
mais je doutais pas dans mes rêves 2,43
tout impôt oui il veut faire nul tu es
s'abattre à venir tels que parmi ses
potes ouais je t'aime c'est cette grille
ça me rassure un peu pour lui ou pour
toi pour les deux
hagrid show qu'il a fait quoi à la
grille je suis là je tiens le coup j'ai
dit normalement c'est parce que tu as
envie john a donc j'ai voulu y là il n'a
pas voulu rentrer dans la prépa melilla
rentrer dans l'autre donc des cupcakes 5
1 tu pars pas de pièces mais ces
équilibristes
mais ok ça ça peut être compensation
encaissé cinq jeux prend un coup sur
deux donc avait à cette enquête je me
lasse bk d'un petit doigt le bcap qui a
aidé deux et ça c'est la pression que tu
auras un karim cavaliers le succès genre
de pression que green ch combiné
ouais en faisant une baïne attaque à la
main à l'ancienne là où il est très bon
en fait bien donc ouais avec des
fourrages c'est que j'ai cinq barrages 4
qui peuvent arriver
non notre s'éclater censé connaître les
défenses du coût attendu je regarde ce
qu'ils ont joué moi j'aurais jamais
mangé le pion mais peut-être que tu es
obligé des gens en fait j'écris vallée
sacha et l'ag juge mitchell bombe
il dit qu'il fallait prendre mesdames
décati sorte fois f5 que j'ai pas vu non
je ne sais pas j'ai pas compris encore
cas et c'est ça que je suis enfermé ou
quoi lesquelles près pas de mal à nos
corps me laisse tomber cette montre est
donc d'un processeur qui répondait train
qu'elle ferait pas encore assez y est il
est fatigant même tous les jours après
ils ont des comptes à bercy après j'en
ai mon ordi mathieu non mais c'est pas
que ça c'est qu'il faut boire l'énergie
de tous les jours chercher bouzid ils
doivent aller chercher à on avance quoi
je ne trouve pas le matin non mais
surtout non mais j'avais deux derniers
mois tous les jours ils ont cherché des
idées et mais le truc c'est qu'ils nous
trouvent et qui en a beaucoup qui
cherchent et qui trouvent rien demande
qu'est ce que c'est une attaque à la
main à l'ancienne bah c'est juste sur un
même pied tranquillement et à l'ancienne
à l'ancienne au couteau
hors cac valeo 2 il n'a pas voulu se
faire échanger le fou c'est ça d'avoir
un petit plus à qui on avait quatre en
l'air quand même mais un dépôt a pris
les choses sérieusement il a vraiment
bossé il est bien entouré il reste une
heure quarante cinq acteurs jouent tout
impôt donc mais hier j'ai beaucoup aimé
jean quand même sa défense c'était
impressionnant
cependant seeding perd aujourd'hui
mathieu fille c'est fini c'est fini dans
tous les sens potable
mais alors est ce là tu viens de mettre
leurs dix 10 des cinq puis on prend qui
on prend deux buts 3 ça donne clairement
pas en lui ce que je te fais métro si
jean castex 4-6 6-1 pour les noirs
attend tour 1 6t penser le dos ça marche
messieurs message
s'ils n'attaquent à l'ancienne et avant
copenhague est ce qu'il ya une greffe
quatre fous des huit pour revenir l'ail
je parle on s'est peut-être un peu trop
je fait refouler 6 damage 3e centre
pendant en gros pour pas trop ce père
mathieu les bonbons et les blancs sont
mûrs et c'est encore juste une prépa
n'depo il à 1h45
il n'a pas réfléchi encore mais je pense
que j'ai cette position jusqu'au 20e
je peux vérifier maxime rêve de toi je
suis tout et mathieu il n'a pas fait
d'un match 4 bien qu'ils le peuvent
je m'assis comprend un peut-être qu'il
n'a pas vu car elle et j'ai 3 f 5 1
c'était pas évident tout rush 1 tout va
bien c'est sûr mais ça a l'air d'être un
peu mieux pour les plans maintenant et
mathieu ouais après c'est pas la fin du
monde il va échanger
non mais c'est pas grave je veux juste
dire que peut-être d'un mach 4 5 c'était
peut-être les noirs qui se mettaient à
presser c'est un grand mot est tour à
tour à je suis tour à chasser les plans
qui reste un peu de vent ouais un peu de
s'ouvrir un peu déçu mais après
cavaliers à 5 qui force les change de
toutes les tours probablement parce que
fout des trois-tours anciens va me
prendre pour un échange de tout des
tours je vais arrêter un gadget esprit
adams est ok ca c
ça va faire nul très serré le pion h 6 h
7 g 4 oui meyer s'est passé les blancs
qui sont un peu mieux parce que ce que
je veux dire par là mathieu c'est que
tout à l'heure n'est peut-être une
position nul et c'était les noirs qui
pouvait peut-être précédent et là c'est
nul et c'est les blancs qui peuvent
pressé c'est juste ça la différence mais
ça change pas le bassin c'est avec un
tout petit avantage mais petit avantage
blanc sait pas c'est rien d'incroyable
quoi et c'est fou hein mais je regardais
la théorie de la partie 2 le donné peau
faisait cinq villages ou d'amd cette
digne il avait déjà juin 2010 9 en
décembre
des tels madame century tour atx elle va
le faire qu'il prendrait quatre mais il
ya tout qui gagne non je vais juste
faire thierry prend des cartes
je suis à la fin il ya des matches huit
ans
pourtant ici et là cinq magistrats match
mais je pense que je peux le faire en
plein de 105
j'aurais pu faire peut-être plus simple
je suis ton premier jeu menace maths je
fais trois styles et je fais dame france
était plus simple pour nous sommes
tentés point ya plus besoin
et même si la wii mais ferme et à cayeux
de cap bep s'inquiète sur le tour b1 qui
à yorick tant français que toi je suis
john ou un tour à tour de john mais
c'est pas vrai que maxime refuse la nuit
les gars parce que tu as match 4
cavaliers g3 f5 pas deux nuls ça il a
peut-être juste pas vu ou alors il n'ya
pas cru est d'ailleurs peut-être que ça
à faire injuste on n'a pas d'ordi
prononce un juste s'avérer intéressant
mais il faut pas lire mais si on avait
l'impression que ça faisait vraiment nul
parce que j'en pense toujours à schwyz
tu refuses nuls et jouer mais je pense
pas fan moi parce que son tour un chien
et visages les a5 et au mieux les films
oui donc c'est pas nous c'est juste
qu'il n'a pas vu et on tourne un peu
moins bien parce qu'il n'a pas trop de
plans le fameux problème ma fille qui
dit à mach 4 3 et enfin d'un machin est
nulle loi rsa aussi erwan le damage 4 kg
3 de 9,6
aussi mes attaches 4,3 f1 tu peux si tu
fais tout rage suite maintenant toute
façon c'est mieux que dans l'autre
position
c'est juste qu'il n'a pas vu mais bon
nous on a le petit ordi qui nous aident
et c'est beaucoup plus facile hein bien
entendu c'est pas du tout une critique
envers le jeu de maxime c'est juste que
l'homme d'apparence de son ordi on avait
vu que y'avait damas a besoin de suite
on est à mach 4 cette année si staline
lui mais eux ça que j'avale clowns
mascottes aidé à me prendre quatre ça
fait au moins un nul à temps à moins
qu'ils aient des cinq à dessin qu'avait
lieu ce tour a changé d'âme ce range
étroit c'est joli et gamecube non mais
non on a le petit ordi qui nous aident
et c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup plus
facile pour nous de voir mais c'est
juste pour dire que tout va ensuite
c'est pas genre je veux jouer je te
donnerai pas là nul c'est juste dommage
que ce n'est peut-être pas si facile à
trouver et tour à schwyz et le deuxième
meilleur coup quoi en tout cas c'est le
coup logique qui veut tout et échanger
et faire nul quand même ça m'inquiète
pas du tout un plat de ça je pense pas
que qui est un réel problème pour pour
les noirs ici attends je vais remettre
une petite pub
mathieu non je regarde ces billets même
parti compte précis n'est pas dans la
partie ii j'essaie de comprendre quelle
est la différence
[Musique]
j'essaie de comprendre et de comprendre
quelle erreur
bon je suis choqué que ding répète
encore mais il est beaucoup beaucoup
trop prévisible savent l'albanie c'est
un livre ouvert
mais du coup la cip et en descente dames
des 4 et 5
alors ce qu'on va regarder c'est la
position est donc bloquée non mesdames
b5 et un écart était de bloquer une tour
en b 6 comment tu vas faire pour pas
perdre le pion de ce qu'ils aillent a
encore soif 6 donc ok donc tourbe et 8
est un poème l'autre du coup ça par
mégarde une pression énorme se sont
baissées je veux avoir du tour à 5 un
jour donc b5l m suffit de torah 5 g en b
6 je veux pas qu'il pousse trop loin et
que d'après je fais fouet six tombes et
8 et j'attends maya kf4 ça va pas les 1
bah en fait ça va aller que si tu
réussis à me bloquer matour en b2 pour
protéger mais j'aimerais organiser leur
bail père bizarre ce qu'il a fait une
tournée 3 et elle prend des 4 donc je
vais a fait tomber deux au 16e stand
moi j'avais c4
ouais donc peu de nouveautés mes parents
de six bières c'est que c'est pas la
ligne principale dame de cette session
c'est pas de meilleur frais cinéma
jacques adgé cup c'était il m'avait dit
que c'était la prépa de magnus
contrecarrer les kings park on va dire à
jean ping c'est les ouvertures c'est
hélas jeux taurins
[Musique]
que pensez-vous de n'est pas qu'ici
bonne prépa des prépa il s'est juste et
même contre caruana lille c'est juste
pas trop rappeler ne pas oublier quoi 13
tonnes c'est dans matt damon est
maintenant c'est une série amazon mais à
la base c'est un projet dans d'un jason
bourne quoi le film de matt damon hill
et jeffrey f5 tempo t'as vu ouais c'est
beaucoup plus fort que cahill c5 un
guinéen énorme tente développement qui
accueille des deux maintenant je dansais
5 ça change quoi
mata change que t'as pas le temps de
faire tous ces deux pour attaquer à
l'ancienne exactement taurin dame boul
28 tu prépares pour éviter ou buffo à
deux fois double à pékin
donc tu as peut-être pas le temps de
taureaux mais ouais les foyers sain qui
t'empêche faut bien et le match pour
avoir la même en ayant je le fous ces
deux quoi c'est un truc avec dom bush
qui a aidé caçapa comment faire marcher
ça peut être moins bien pour les blancs
et quand même des pièces mal placée côté
noir moi il ya des compensations pour
l'option mais c'est encore une grosse
préparation fatigue fait les mieux
préparés pour le mans c'est caruana une
époque m les périls et maxime l es4
qu'on a mis favori n'a pas guéri alors à
tanger l'échiquier qui a disparu c'est
pas trop pourquoi et l'échiquier
c'est elle qui tire en dessous
[Rires]